Hello and welcome the fire of learning
and the next few videos we're going to be
doing an overview of what is it called,
the Viking age.
The Viking age began in the late eighth
century and lasted until the mid 11th
century,
marked by the beginning of raids on
neighboring settlements by Norris Raiders
and known as the Vikings.
The word Viking,
very likely is it related to plundering,
exploring and or adventuring their
influence on European society.
Language and culture was a major having
lasting effects which influence us to
this day.
They were in many ways an early medieval
power influencing societies from Spain
to southern Italy to Russia and feared
and known all the way from Canada to the
Middle East.
They're sea fairing
abilities and exploratory
accomplishments predate the rest
of Europe, hundreds of years settling
places like Greenland, Iceland,
and discovering and even colonizing
North America hundreds of years before
Christopher Columbus was even born.
They were an accomplished but
also misunderstood people.
As much of what we know about them came
from accounts from their enemies and
therefore much work has been done in
dispelling many misconceptions and false
ideas.
Considering the fact that a lot of
misinformation about vikings exist here,
even on other channels on Youtube,
I've been extra careful to
avoid information that is
in factual. In this video,
we're going to talk about the history
of Scandinavia leading up to the Viking
age and a number of events occurring
in their homeland and in Europe,
which have very likely contributed
and caused the Viking age.
The Vikings came from the region
known today as Scandinavia,
which today is Denmark,
Sweden, and Norway.
This region had historically
been occupied by dramatic tribes.
Many of these tribes went on to evolve
into the north societies at the vikings
came from during the time of the Roman
of the region was largely cut off from
the Roman empire being
separated by Germany,
which successfully repelled room invasions
and halted their desire to expansion
northward.
However,
archeological evidence proves that Roman
goods did make their way into lower
Scandinavia and tribes from their
region did at times participate in wars
against the Romans,
particularly those from modern Denmark
being mixed in with the other nearby
Germanic tribes.
The people here were fairly interesting.
They had somewhat
democratic tribal societies.
In which all land owning men and in fact
the land owning women without a husband
to present them.
How does say in the tribe a system which
didn't really change until the later
iron age when we're like kings
began to take over the society,
Kingswood later support the material
wealth of their societies by plundering
others.
However,
even in these societies in Norris had
a democratic undertone to their culture
and society and many land owners in
North Society's believes that they should
have a say in their chiefs in or later
kings decisions following the fall of the
Roman empire.
The peoples of this area enter into
what's called the Germanic irony age.
And notably this is the same time
period in which the Danes Appearance
Scandinavia.
The Danes spoke a similar Norse language
as that of other tribes in places like
Sweden and Norway.
And they sell them parts of both of
these places in northern Germany and of
course for the most part, the Danish
march or what is today called Denmark.
So these north societies begin to take
shape and evolve in such and eventually
the people here have an urge to expand.
And explore and migrate to new places,
but people here began to build great
warships, develop newer technologies,
and began raiding various places
and even eventually settling,
knew previously undiscovered lands, thus
marking the beginning of the Viking age.
But the question is why.
I mean to be fair,
Scandinavia wasn't exactly the spotlight
of your prior to this point in history.
What reasons and events drove them to
begin this highly influential Viking age?
Well, a number of things were going on
at this time in Europe and very likely a
combination of factors contributed
to the sparking of this age.
One factor is possibly that Scandinavia
at this time was becoming overpopulated.
Scandinavia is a cold and not particularly
fertile region and this of course is
place limitations on agriculture and
general food production and obviously the
population might have
been restricted by this.
This is something which
stuck with a Scandinavian
nations throughout history and
even today, their populations
are still comparatively smaller.
It's entirely likely that people having
such a region want to go out and raid
other societies for resources and
eventually settled out other areas.
It wasn't necessarily that they
were just sick of the weather.
Some of these places like
Iceland and Greenland,
we're not much more a
group of apple climates,
but they were open territories with land
available for set for settlement and
the vikings were interested
in that especially because
it was an opportunity to
get away from the burdens of Viking
kings in politics and as such have their
home nations and politics based on the
Viking accounts were definitely motive
for emigration.
However,
there isn't much evidence to support the
idea that there was a famine occurring
in Scandinavia at this time.
There may have indeed been enough for
the population to get by. However,
there may have been some problems with
the population itself in North Society at
the time,
there was a heavy emphasis on having
male children to the point at which,
and fantasize sometimes occurred
towards female children.
This while being sad and cruel and
itself was likely responsible for an
imbalance in the sexism.
Many norths men were motivated,
motivated to find wives and begin families
and other lands where there were more
women.
However,
the fact that they didn't just go and
bring women back kind of suggests that
this was not the main
driving force either.
Another major event to take
into consideration here
is that the beginning of
this age occurs at the same time
as both Charlotte, his empire,
and the increased spread of Christianity.
The Nourse who were pagans were very
concerned about the Frankish empire,
the Franks being the early French,
especially as the empire went right on
their southern border and some conflict
occurred, especially as Christianity
spread throughout Scandinavia.
The North's peoples were rather
abrasive to Christianity. In fact,
that Christian forces often simply killed
Scandinavians who refuse to convert to
the religion, did not encourage
them to change their perspective.
Many people believe that the vikings
may have felt compelled to defend their
societies and religion and general
way of life from the foreign threats,
and even though Charlemagne's empire
began to decline heavily after his death,
they may have pursued this defensiveness
and use it as justification during the
Viking age, especially
because Christianity did
not go away. Another motive,
quite simply is just that they
may have known that they could,
they were developing new technologies,
specifically better tools,
weapons and warships. They were
becoming a more organized society,
and importantly, some of their
neighbors were weak, fragmented,
and susceptible to attack and history
across the world unfortunately shows that
when the strong have an opportunity to
take from the week, they jump on it.
And that's precisely what the Vikings did.
One of those weaker neighbors was north
Umbria, a predecessor to English society,
where in the year 793 the
Viking age began. And what?
Talking about that in the next video to
keep up with this series and for more
videos like this and
on many other subjects,
be sure to check out fire of learning
and subscribed. Thank you for watching.